очевидно що треба книги читати тобто я
звичайно за популяризацію якісь новітні
канали YouTube канали але книга все-таки
дає можливість глибше зануритися в
минуле Необов'язково якісь академічні
видання інколи заходиш в будь-яку
українську книгарню е-е книги з
української історії це вже навіть не
паличка А це вже по суті цілий відділ і
серед цієї літератури багато як раз
науково-популярної літератури це і вже
згадано Історична правда має свою
бібліотеку на кілька книжок була дуже
цікава ініціатива ліг-бесіка теж свого
часу опублікувала десятитомний
популярний
популярний історії України і крім того
ще кілька націй якихось інших книжок
дуже багато літератури цікавої
літератури науково-популярною Було
підготовлено виготовлено українським
інституту національної пам'яті який
очолював до 19-го року і вся ця
літературу є безкоштовно для закачування
всіх можливих потрібних форматах не
тільки PDF і пап мобі на всі ваші
електронні книжки беріть і качайте
читайте поглиблюйте свої знання